[Applause]
hey what's up guys it's good to be here
my name is Hans Kim and I'm not a very
intimidating fella I can tell by the way
you guys are still on board with this
premise one feels really safe right now
it kind of makes me insecure something
about my presence inspires confidence in
others leader of men I suddenly feel
like testing the limits of my physical
abilities but I could inspire that kind
of confidence I'm not a big fan of
crowds crowds are my least favorite
thing next to individuals the visuals
indentity the crowds so American I don't
understand people who brag about having
been spanked apparently you weren't
spanked hard enough because you're still
an arrogant person I saw I saw a Netflix
special recently that had canned
laughter on it
and that kind of annoyed me as a
comedian you know what if instead of
Canada laughter why don't you just dumb
it better jokes
you have the technology whether we can
fake 500 genuine human emotions or we
can get one guy to work harder the thing
you're famous for I live in my car so I
can sue somebody full-time so if you
don't think I'm very funny
I'm sorry I'm trying my hardest I really
don't know what more I could be doing
puts a lot of pressure on me now now
people are like yeah that was funny but
not living your car funny
[Laughter]
I'm gonna open an apartment buddy I woke
up today and I was like I wonder what
the temperature outside is like and I
was like probably exactly the same as
the temperature it's where the science
works
it's up to date as a van dweller things
like shelter person wants to go home
with me is we go for a drive that's all
I can work up the courage to tell her we
arrived 45 minutes
[Applause]